so good afternoon everyone and welcome
to this council meeting welcome to those
of you in the chamber and also those of
you joining us from home and live stream
we'll start by taking apologies and Mia
Clarke is an apology he's in Wellington
on business
are there any other apologies
and if not
and if not someone moved thank you then
someone second those in favor say aye
aye against carried thank you
we have no public forum today
so we'll
move on there is a major layer item in
the agenda which is the minutes of the
risk and Assurance committee meeting
held on the 21st of March
um we'll hear those later but will
someone move that we
um read it thank you Leslie
and seconded Trish those in favor say
aye against kharid
moving on we have the minutes of the
meeting of council held on the 28th of
February
or somebody moves that we received those
please thank you Ria
um seconded Barry was in favor say aye
aye against carried
link you we move on to the minutes of
the extraordinary meeting of the risk
and Assurance committee held on the
Tuesday the 7th of March or Sunday move
that we receive those
thank you fresh and thank you Leslie for
sickening those in favor say aye aye aye
games carried
we have the minutes of the extraordinary
meeting of council held on Tuesday the
7th of March or someone move that we
received those
thanks Barry thank you Leslie for
seconding those in favor say aye against
carried
um
sorry at the extraordinary risk and
insurance
I'll move
okay okay
thank you
so moving on to the minutes of the
meeting of the infrastructure committee
held on Tuesday the 7th of March there
is a recommendation which comes from the
meeting so we'll take this in two parts
um firstly uh Wrangler you move that we
received the owl move that we receive
the minutes and also
um move the recommendation the council
accepts a recommendation
um will someone second
cute is it any uh discussion on the
recommendation
no okay so well
um so those in favor say aye
against
carried
so we moved to the minutes of the
meaning of the community well-being
committee
um held on Tuesday the 14th of March
move the receipt second thank you thank
you uh listen favor
aye was against carried
move to the minutes of the meaning of
the bluff community board held on Monday
the 20th of March were Sunday moves that
we received those
thank you
so
thank you seconded
thank you Leslie who's in favor I was
against carried
takes us to the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of the finance and
projects committee held on Tuesday the
21st of March
when someone moves that we receive those
thank you Barry seconded thank you
uh those in favor say aye
aye against carried
so that takes us to item 12 the long
term plan
so who's speaking to that Rhiannon
thank you
foreign
councilors so um this paper deals
primarily with the outcomes from the
community well-being Workshop held a few
weeks ago so it provides you with an
opportunity to consider the topics
discussed at that workshop and just
confirm the direction I'll go through
those in a moment or we'll just flag
this report also provides a risk
management update on the delivery of the
long-term plan itself the one thing that
I would just like to flag with you is
that the biggest risk to the delivery of
the long-term plan does Remain the three
Waters reform
at present our strategy is that we will
in case of the three Waters reform not
occurring use the NTU plans Asset
Management plans however this is going
to cause the requirement for an
amendment of The ltp probably the year
in in the immediate first year of the
ltp so I just wanted to flag that that
risk is still if we are managing it it
is being actively managed by the chief
executive
um the other thing that I will flag is
just that we are in good shape we are on
progress we're having productive
conversations at these strategic
workshops and that is flowing through
into the rest of the process there is
um
resources are tight within the staff
team in terms of delivering so again
just flagging that while we are not
um while there are not significant
issues at this point that
we do not have much contingency much
space within capacity
so in terms of the community well-being
factors considered the workshop really
focused primarily on the issue of social
well-being the priority that you had as
a council through your first Community
outcome to ensure that there's a good
level of service in the city so that we
considered issues around extension for
services of recycling
curbside collection
um
buses full Bluff
also discussed priorities for the area
of Community Development
so
um all of these issues are provided here
for you to consider and confirm
so Rhiannon um
I I think you know I haven't read this
this reflects it seems to me
um exactly the discussion that we held
you know over a much longer period
obviously um two weeks ago when we had
our Workshop I don't see anything in
here which is different from that is it
anything is different do you think is
there any entity highlight which is
um in any respect different from the
things that we discussed two weeks ago
no I always try to work as hard as
possible to as closely reflect your
conversation
as as we can so you can be assured it
reflects the conversation and it's just
now obviously this is the formal
decision making process so now as you
you know chance if anyone has
reconsidered it so are there any
questions for Rhiannon
done it's region no not not any
questions I I'm more than happy to to
move the recommendations and in doing so
it I think we should point out that
whilst those are the directions that we
indicated from the workshop that doesn't
necessarily mean it's the the final
stop-off point this is what we take out
for consultation and if people disagree
with what we've said are our preferences
at this point then obviously through
that consultative process they had the
chance to feed that back to us okay so
before we you says you've moved other
questions before we do okay
um sorry I'll keep running first and and
then Grant
thank you
Mr Deputy Mayor
um
look my concern is is recommendation two
and the the realization that this
consultation's not going up to March
next year
um and then any action on uh recycling
of well sorry the separation of glass
from the recycling system
is going to not come into play if it
goes ahead until the very end of next
year in fact the museum will probably be
built before this happens so I I
actually place a lot more urgency on the
separation of glass out of this some
real problems and unfortunately well
this is our chance to say it I
this this needs a different process
to get to a result sorry rather than the
ltp that's my as chairman structure
and my understanding of
the way this would would pan out this is
too slow
let me ask him around in the the this
suggest this is uh an options paper will
come back to council how quickly do you
think that that'll happen
I think that's probably a question for
the GM of infrastructure about whether
this would be able to be sped up I would
think though passing these
recommendations here does not mean that
that could not then be accelerated if
that was appropriate but I would yeah I
mean I don't think the question is so
much about accelerating the action or
like except that's what Ryan says would
be good but I think initially what we
need is a if we can get a paper faster
the options paper faster
um thank you chair
what I would say is that there's a
significant amount of work in developing
the options paper
um it is something that would you know
normally be delivered in the lead up to
a long-term plan to a significant change
to a level of service so that that's
probably the the usual place that you
would you would bring in a new change to
a level of service
um in terms of of timing what I'd say is
that council's already accelerated some
pretty significant projects 12 25 being
one of them
um I would probably struggle with the
ability to accelerate this one beyond
the point that it is at the moment but
obviously I'll take direction from
Council around where priorities should
be focused going forward
is a different question everyone
I just wonder
how big a deal it is for us to look at
some practical solution that we suggest
to our community that they do in terms
of it's a problem with glass and air
burns and I think that
having
um
a longer term strategy is a good thing
but what can we do
next week
because of this if it's such a problem
that it is creating expense it's
creating risks in terms of health and
safety all those things then shouldn't
we be looking at what can we do tomorrow
what can we suggest that will make that
change and if it's as simple as we all
have a cardboard box that we put our
bottles in and
we ring somebody and say who's going to
who's prepared to come and collect it
whatever I don't know the answer but I
think there's got to be something
simpler than waiting 18 months
Aaron I guess the cardboard box auction
may be a bit harder but I mean Central
collection points for example is that
something that could be
um tackle faster
um absolutely it's an option to explore
some interim options in in this space
um and bottle banks have definitely been
used as as interim options for councils
um I guess at a similar place in the
journey to what we are
um what I would say though is bottle
Banks if you're going to remove glass
from the waste stream
um then you basically say to people that
would like to that they can use the
bottle bank and others can put their
glass into into the landfill stream
um
in my experience there's quite often a
backlash around that because
um it is then perceived that council's
primary option is to be landfilling a
recyclable material
um so we would need to work through the
pros and cons
um of a step like that okay so we're
obviously want to chase it then today
but if we can at least ask that you
consider some interim State that would
be that would demonstrate that you know
the council series pushing the smart
forward
thank you Rihanna invite T oh sorry I
was taken um I was taking questions
Grant
yeah mine's in relation to point success
with um
the review of the public
transport options
um
we're having the word bus in there sort
of tends to make people think about or a
bus is the auction whereas I think I'd
like to see it driven from the community
around what exactly is the need and how
can we meet the need that may not in
fact be a bus option so different
options around the
you know providing a public transport a
service but it may not be a bus so I
just think it's important that we
perhaps take the word bus out of that
process and so we get a very clear lens
on what the need in that Community is
and how we can best cater for it
um okay no I think I think we'll leave
that point as it stands we did discuss
that this morning actually in the um in
the workshop
um and I think you know we are going to
look at broader range of options
other questions
okay if not then will somebody move that
we receive
um link done second degree
um it doesn't pay for say I I
against character
so that takes us to the paper 13 the
annual Plan update
okay
so this report on the annual plan
provides council with a picture of where
the preparation on the annual plan is at
this point in time and also provides the
advice from officers that consultation
is not
required on the annual plan on this
occasion so the report outlines the
reasons for that I'm going to touch on
the key points and then Patricia is here
to answer specific questions that you
may have about particular Financial
elements of the annual plan position
so the paper talks through
issues relating to the capital program
and strategic projects it notes all
those areas of
um where there are variances to the
long-term plan and two decisions made as
part of last year's annual plan and
notes that none of these variances reach
the level of significance
bits talks in detail about three Waters
and depreciation as this is one of the
major issues for this plan it is a
unique plan because it will be based on
the current reform program the last year
for Council operation of three Waters
within the district
um so I will draw attention to two
points the first that the level of
investment is set at the same amount
within the three Waters program as it
was forecast within the long term plan
and also it this report speaks to how
Council will treat the matter of
depreciation in relation to this year of
the plan and notes that it is an
alignment with advice that we have
received so the really important thing
to take away is that the program will
focus on maintaining levels of service
and ensuring good standards of delivery
within the three Waters area of
maintaining human health
um
but that there will be an impact on the
depreciation strategy for Council
so Rihanna could I just
part of Frieza sort of I understand it
correctly we're seeing that we are going
to do the work which Asset Management
says that we require to do what needs to
be done the maintenance work that needs
to be done in those assets rather than
Target an expenditure which is you know
relatively artificial drop in a
depreciation but we are still going to
do all of the asset management work
which is required
we are going to fund to the level of
which was forecast for the third year it
is certainly not the original program
that was put forward by the
infrastructure team and the GM of
infrastructure may wish to speak to this
more but you can be assured that the
amount is appropriate to cover the
must-dos within the program
um do you want to come in here
um look I might I might comment slightly
differently
um we we all know that um there's an
infrastructure deficit in New Zealand
and that councils need to be really
committed to continuing to invest in
that space
um we've
um there's obviously pressure on the
budgets at the moment and we can take
direction from counselors to where to
prioritize the expenditure that is
available
um I can't give you guarantees though
that that means that we will be able to
cover all of the must do's
we may be in a situation where we may
see some more as as I've discussed
previously some more failures on our
reticulation Network in particular
okay thank you carry on
so in the area of the operational
budgets
um
obviously there are a significant cost
increases right across the plan from
inflation from increased interest rates
and you're seeing this in the
operational area significant savings
were found but these unfortunately have
been offset by increases
um which are detailed in the report
um I'll just note that the fees and
charges are still out for consultation
at this point at present the draft
annual plan is based on the fees and
charges that we went out for
consultation with if you make different
decisions following that consultation
that would affect
um the final position
inflation and interest rates obviously
I've touched on briefly but this is a
significant impact for this plan
um obviously the whole Community is
being affected by these issues is
probably important to note for the
community that the council interests or
sorry inflation rate is a little
different to the community inflation
rate because the basket of services that
Council purchases is different we use
the bill local government cost index and
we have forecasts based on that rate it
is higher than was anticipated at the
time of the long-term plan interest
rates are having a significant impact
and that has been forecasting
um
there are changes to staff costs
particularly linked to the minimum wage
um and to managing inflation
there are some changes to income and
you'll recall from the discussions
around the last annual plan that there
are significant subsidies coming through
the budget at the moment linked to three
Waters transition and that is affecting
the revenue forecasts
um
so I would touch briefly and I'm sure
Patricia may actually say more on this
in a moment and that is that we are just
signaling that there will be important
as part as the ltp to develop a strong
plan for returning to a balanced budget
this annual plan this year focuses on
cost of living and supporting the
community by managing the rates increase
it will result in an unbalanced budget
yeah so
um I think
that I will leave it there I will just
note the financial implications are all
laid out there for you in terms of where
this draft plan at this time lies in
relation to all the benchmarks that
council is required to monitor as I've
signaled probably the balance budget
benchmarks the most important thing to
consider
um
and if it's okay chair I'll just pause
there and perhaps
Patricia if you had anything else that
you wish to flag at this point
I think nothing additional to play I
just want to reiterate in relation to
the balanced budget
we can run an unbalanced budget for a
year we do have to have a plan about how
we're going to return to a balanced
budget
um it's not that we've got a slightly
unbalanced budget we are the forecast is
14 to 15 million dollars unbalanced
thanks to depreciation
um so it is something that we're going
to have to look at very closely and
potentially do things differently as
part of the ltp so you need to there'll
be some
discussions that we'll have during the
workshops as we come through the
financing strategy
and those that will come up in in coming
months but we may need to think have
some new ideas come to the table on
there
Patricia
Grant yeah just um with respect to on
page two of your report 49 on board box
um the comment around
um this building and
may need an additional rates increase
for maintenance what what is their
um policy around how we allocate
maintenance within our budgets
what's that one to the GM of
infrastructure
so traditionally we've used it basically
a bottom-up approach to building those
maintenance and and renewals budgets
um the team have come together worked
across the various different teams of
council
um you know from Splash Palace to our
Parks buildings obviously to this
building
um and looked at what what needs to be
done and how we prioritize that work
what I'd say is that
um there's it's probably one of the
lower areas of asset management maturity
in our business and something that we
need to continue to work on
um it's definitely left us with a a
deficit of investment across multiple of
our buildings this one included
secondary Christian search here so it
would be good to see what 80 percent
actually is because we're going to have
to do something about that and with
um
Patricia's comment about you know we
need to get a balanced budget but we've
got a looming under investment in
maintenance in our infrastructure then
you know building infrastructure in
particular then that's a serious
potential issue so it would be good to
see a report on what exactly a gap is
between where we're at today and how
we've allocated for that cost so
specific to this building there is a
report coming in April
um to discuss that deferred maintenance
on this building yeah but I think what
you've uncovered is across all assets
right so absolutely which is where we've
changed our asset management approach to
a number of our areas including property
so there is now rather than a property
team who are everybody is dealing in the
fires every day we've actually got
people who are dedicated to that
forward-looking Asset Management piece
of work but it's going to take a little
while for us to reap the benefits of
that work okay so we we'd be like to see
a report from it
I'll go away and have a chat to the team
and come back to you okay thank you any
other questions
foreign
when we
know that citizens are struggling as
inflation you know goes above seven
percent and everything seems to be
becoming more more expensive and
particularly things like food
um it was one of the duties we had this
year I think to try to keep rates
increase down to the absolute minimum
that we could
um as a consequence of that I think
we've we've cut far whatever we could
um we have you know made decisions which
ideally you would have spent the money
but in fact we've decided no this is not
the year when we can take even more
money from ratepayers than we then we
may otherwise do
um but we've got to a point where if we
cut any further we would be cutting
muscle and bone rather than you know
rather than fat so I think it's uh it's
a Pity that we've ended up with a rates
increase which now looks as though it's
going to be about 5.5 that's higher than
word of light
but it's still an awful lot lower than
it may have been had we taken other
decisions so I I think we've probably
landed in a place which is as good as
we're going to get to even recognizing
the fact that if we had more money that
our um you know there are other things
that we'd like to have spent that money
on
um so I think it's a good compromise
from from that point of view
if there's no other questions Leslie I
was just
a block
thank you well someone's second thanks
Trish
um is there any further discussion
if not then
um all those in favor say aye aye
against carried thank you
could I just take you back for a moment
to the a previous top Community
well-being
um when we moved uh I only really spoke
to move item one and not list on page 43
of board books
um Dan you
um moved I think in the presumption we
were removing all of those items
is that correct but I did I did ask what
we you know we moved to receive
um but can I just put it again the
motion again just to make sure
everybody's comfortable that we are
confirming all 10 of those points
um so those in favor say aye against
carried thank you thanks for pulling
that in Michael
so we'll go back
to a tab 14 which is the climate change
update in Rhiannon it's obviously your
time to speak at the
um Council today we we've heard um we
obviously spent quite a long term time
in this subject this morning
um we spent about an hour talking about
it we largely covered the things which
are included in your paper but
nevertheless I'll just give you the
opportunity before we take further
questions to you know say anything that
you that you wish at this point
thank you chair so yes we have
workshopped this today as part of the
long-term plan process so I won't go
into it in a huge amount of detail I
think I'll just say it is
um very timely and environment south end
until marama to be congratulated for
beginning the regional working group
um this report really provides council
with an update on all the work that
invercargill city council has been doing
independently in the meantime the
Strategic Focus that we have had both on
emissions reduction and on um getting
the information together which will be
necessary to enable you as a council to
make decisions around what might be
needed in the area of adaptation
so it's really
um just an opportunity for you to note
the progress in delivering the priority
areas of focus outlined in the current
long-term plan
so questions to Rhiannon
nice rangi
uh thank you chair look mine's just
around
I guess consistency with the climate
change reporting and language we're
using now that talks about our baseline
from invercargill City Council
um
and acknowledges the amount of tons that
we produce
but in our if you look at our Council
reports you'll see subsections that list
climate change
now I want to bring your attention to
the council report from January 31 and
it was regarding the delegation to
kumagaya
and in that report
it lists
under climate change
the state's not applicable now
um most corporates would look at
overseas travel as a direct impact on
climate change and and using the
calculation formulas that are in this
report
um sending the five people person
delegation is equivalent to 33 tons of
CO2 now that's not negligible now should
we be reporting that when we bring
something like the kumagaya trip to
council and state its impact rather than
saying it's not a
it's not applicable because I actually
believe that when we talk about
something like international travel with
a delegation if we're going to be
consistent to everything else we're
doing here we actually need to
um rather than talk to talk is actually
walk the walk so I would think a gorilla
totally easy in any circumstance where
we are proposing for Council to travel
that we include in the paper the number
of tons of CO2 which would be
um I mean I would think that would be
straightforward wouldn't it so I think
that's a good idea actually unless you
do that and it may and it may be just
that I suspect the next question it it
might be that once a year we should get
advised to many tons of CO2 through
General travel generally a travel by
Executives and so forth I mean I would
think that'd be real and I think it is
appropriate to be to know what that data
is I guess whereas coming from if that
information was there I guess the debate
on going to kumagaya may have looked at
a different angle and looked at is is it
um is it worth it you know for the for
what we're doing with the 33 tons of CO2
or you know there would have been a
contemplation unfortunately that choice
wasn't there so I'm just it would be
great if if those things were included I
I think another question of course is
whether we purchase offsets when we do
your travel and and you know one we are
mitigating that um would be if it did
purchased offsets for the for the
flights because obviously that's an
option when you when you book a flight
you can click the button that says that
you you know you buy offsets
it's more it's more the consistency that
I'm worried about as on one hand we're
talking about it and then in our reports
it seems to be
like it's it's a bit random I would say
I think the point is well made so I I
think two things I would suggest is one
is that
um you know maybe we do buy offset
conscious offsets for the 33 tons that
we're we're going to use which will be
um sorry Rihanna you're going to come in
wait till you finish your well I I think
that and I think the other point that
you made let's make sure that whenever
we are traveling that's brought to this
table
Rihanna all I wanted to speak to really
was the point that we discussed in the
workshop that this is a journey and that
we are quite close towards the beginning
of that Journey as the organization
matures will certainly be able to
provide more specific information in the
example that character celeb pottinger
gives being able to give carbon
emissions for travel is easier than it
will be for specific advice in many
areas I just want to flag that we do not
yet have the resources knowledge across
areas to provide specific detailed
advice you will still be getting general
advice in the area of um of um climate
change within your reports for a while
yet the consultant that's worked with us
on this first carbon Baseline
um
has estimated some areas which is a
normal part of the process as we
increase our knowledge over time the
data will get more specific and reliable
but just to flag it is labor-intensive
it is not going to be simple to provide
for every report thank you as you see
it's sort of we're on a journey actually
it's relatively easy we see a travel
because every time you book a year
ticket the idling tells you how much so
you're generating so you know that's
certainly possible anyway other
questions for Rhiannon
okay well we had a really good
discussion about this this morning I
mean it does seem to mean I I gave the
metaphor particularly in terms of
mitigation we we produce 15 000 tons of
um carbon dioxide a year
um if we were to work on trying to
reduce that we probably could get it and
that's that's category wanted category
four that's all CO2 from not only our
own activities but the activities of
people who are selling as Goods
um the if we worked harder than that if
we got it doing Say by 50 so that we
were say seven at eight thousand tons
um just to get to
uh you know that that is one fiftieth
150 is two percent of the CO2 emitted by
Ty for example
um if we were to decide to uh purchase
offsets for that it would probably cost
us about half a million dollars a year
to purchase offsets if we were to plant
trees to mitigate that it would be about
500 hectares of near the forest would
mitigate that
um so it's you know I think we can
characterize if if we do wish to get
down to Net Zero then I I think I would
characterize it probably is you know
difficulty of claiming Bluff Hill rather
than a difficulty of climbing Mount
Everest it's certainly doable in the the
medium term if we decide to you know
that we do wish to go in there zero in
Fairly within the next few years
um
the the
adjustment though
uh to climate change and particularly
the adjustment to sea level rise
um adaptation
um is more difficult because we really
don't have the data at this point to
decide what the best things to do are
so of course Rihanna's paper and the
paper that we that attached Adriana's
paper just focus in the fight did we do
need data particularly in the relative
Heights of a line collected through
what's called Lida most of that works
being done but so some are still to be
done and there's a lot of analysis to be
done and then we can make decisions
about where we need to go from there but
you know I I'm quite comfortable around
in that I think everything is in hand
and I think we're actually working in
good order and taking us as seriously as
we should
are you
I think so thank you
okay so we are asked to um
receive Rihanna's paper
into note the things that she lists
on that page
so somebody moves that please thanks
Leslie
um seconded by Alex is there any more
discussion
I'll just take the move as prerogative
of saying a few words
um yeah I did just want to emphasize
that you and I have both been on the um
the regional climate change working
group I did just want to point out how
positively that Regional working group
has started out we know that there is a
very long path to go down and that the
leader data when it is available is
going to greatly add to the to the work
we're able to do but it has been very
productive with that group led by
environment South and tiara marama to
start the path is what seems to me a
no-brainer as a regional group who can
progress that work
regionally there's so many ways in which
if we try to attack some of these issues
solely as invercargill city council
certainly we have done some very good
work with things we have already done
but to to make the sort of impact we can
make as a region I think this working
group is going to deliver and I'm very
positive about its pathway so
um yeah I'm happy to to move that we
received the report and note all those
various factors okay thank you any other
discussion
so those in favor say aye
aye against kharid Thank You Rihanna
so we moved to tab 15 which is the
electoral murders update
and Michael
you're on
good afternoon thank you
um it's a little bit of a journey from
down there I have to get faster but so
it's uh this paper is just reminding
everybody that there is an election in
2025 and the process to get ready for
that has now started uh so there's just
a couple of things that I'm going to
update you all about the first up is
that
by September this year we will need a
decision on whether the council was to
move to the single transferable vote
electoral system will remain with the
first pass the post system so that is uh
the first
uh sort of topic that kicks off the
election cycle for us
and so the options here realistically
are whether you wish to consult with the
community on this or whether it is a
decision as elected members of the
community you wish to make uh yourselves
you are also entitled to ask the
community in a binding poll
what they think
and they can provide that feedback but
no that would be done through our
electoral officer and would
um come with some cost uh to run so put
that there is that caveat on that
uh the other matters in the paper cover
a representation of you and Maori Ward
issue there is a legislation heading
through Parliament now that could
require us to reconsider or to consider
again for the coming election a question
of Amari Ward uh that is expected to be
enacted in April and should that happen
I will of course bring a paper back to
you as soon as I can to update to
on what that means and what the what
options would be available for you to
consider
as you know on a representation review
for those of you who were here last term
uh that was completed we are required to
do one every six years but there is an
option to do another to to do one in the
third year uh there would be a cost
associated with that but it is an option
that is always available if it is
considered that the
uh if electrical systems say the at
large method for example uh were not
working uh fmr reward was to be adopted
it would automatically trigger the need
for a representation of you and this is
one of the things that the legislation
is changing just to try and better
coordinate the work between
the my reward question and the resulting
representation review is last time
around there was quite a Scramble for
the local electoral uh local government
commission sorry to get all their
decisions out because of the number of
Mighty awards that were created
and the very last point in the paper is
the potential lowering of the voting age
for local government elections as I'm
sure you are aware there was a
declaration of inconsistency made by the
Supreme Court in relation to the
determination that voting should be when
you turn 18.
uh that triggers a process under the
Bill of Rights act that requires
Parliament to look into that and for
there to be a government response the
initial response as proposed by the
previous prime minister and prime
minister adun was to put a bill before
the house to lower the voting age to 16
across the board for both general
election and for our local elections
um that changing electoral law would
require a super majority of 75 percent
of the house and both National and X
said they would not support such a move
under the new prime minister um Hipkins
so I don't know whether we can keep
calling him new he's been there while we
knew
um and the Prime Minister Hopkins he has
said that he is not intending to place
that piece of legislation before the
house because it's doomed to fail so
he's not going to waste valuable time
doing that however I understand that
there is still an intention to pursue
lowering the voting age for
local elections and that would take
effect from 2025.
uh there has been no bill placed before
the house I'm aware I'm just alerting
you to that this is potentially coming
up there are a number of issues that
that can present for us that we would
need to work through uh Chief amongst
those relates to the iot uh given that
you cannot buy
alcohol until you turn 18 should you be
able to vote for people who control
access to and where alcohol is sold
um there are some policy decisions that
our cabinet are going to have to make on
that but again it's an issue that I'm
flagging with you so that you are aware
this is happening as opposed to needing
um anything from you at this stage
should that bill be placed before the
house and submissions are called for we
will of course bring that back to you
and invite a submission to be presented
on behalf of this
council is one of the councils with one
of the largest licensing trusts that
would present us with a bit of an
administrative
burden and as I'm sure you can also
think of the other issue that um the
working group I'm on in relation to this
and to election issues is if 16 year
olds can vote can they also stand
and be a counselor which could result in
um
problems of them attending if they
didn't have to start missing school so
lots of things to be worked through but
again it's just something uh to alert
you to that it's this is happening and
we are expecting to see potential
legislation come through this year
so with that I'm happy to answer any
questions uh welcome to questions uh can
you know some mean first Michael
um when I look at the
um member at large system that we have
and I I was struggling to try to think
how STV would what would that I mean I
would a decision to go to STV inevitably
mean that we would have to decide to go
to watch or is it actually aware
no I'm I'm actually Mr chair thank you
for that question uh having an all-out
large system it perfectly suits an STV
model because everybody the voting
public would be able to vote for um
rank everybody and their preference
right across the entire Council so you
would be able to have at least 12
preferences possibly more
so considering last time we hit
something like 36 candidates you could
rank 1 to 36. and and at large is the
most ideal method for
um an STV system
yeah okay thank you uh other questions
for Michael
thanks I think
thank you Deputy Mia Campbell I'm
actually really pleased that this paper
has come up because when
asking counselors to vote for whether or
not they have
um whether or not we have first pass the
post or stb systems is almost like
asking turkeys to vote for Christmas
um that if first pass the foreign
because the first class the post system
first pass the post system
um lends to
um the loss of votes that leads to a
popularity contest it lends to all sorts
of things that whenever I hear in the
community we just going straight ahead
with it first fast the post without
using asking the community
um I've had feedback from community
members saying oh you know why have you
done that it's just going to end up
being another popularity contest why
don't we get a say in the matter
um especially like if you've got here on
Liverpool report that the future for
local government report clearly states
that STV systems are the most fearest
way for vote distribution in the sense
that if someone gets knocked out the
next person's vote whoever you've
preferentially voted for your vote still
counts towards those candidates so
there's no loss of votes there's no it's
just a lot more ethical and fair so I
would really love to see us put it out
to the community community to let them
tell us what they think we should do
rather than us deciding it
for them for once okay Leslie
thank you
um I'm also those who are at the table
when we last discussed this matter will
know that um my views on the choice
between STV and fpp are very clear as
probably the only person around this
table who has stood in an STV election
end was elected
I have no fears at all about
recommending STV as the preferential
system good answer sorry to
interruptedly could we maybe rather than
debate which is better at this point the
fundamental question is whether we
should put it to consultation so let's
focus on that was my
yeah I am very happy as a counselor to
Beck that we put this out to the public
we've had the discussion around this
table we've all got our personal views
um
the question of
choosing a proportional election system
has been before the New Zealand Public
before
I think the New Zealand Public uh
mature enough to have that conversation
again certainly our invercargill rate
payers are and I would very much bet
that we put it out for consultation
thank you darling I think Eugene handed
up next thanks Jim
um
there's an observation of our last
process it was interesting and and just
anecdotal really that um
males voted One Way females better than
the other as I say that was that was
coincidence and it was one of those who
voted to support first past the post
it may be of interest
for people to realize that my position
on that may have changed
um but to the point where I think
councilor cricket is right that it
should go out and we should get some
feedback I don't think we should go to
the expense of having a poll
but certainly getting some clearer
indication from people on what it is
they would prefer would be useful look
to to be frank they're both popularity
contests that's just kind of how voting
Works
um yeah but
it would be much like a flag referendum
you know a chance for people to at least
have have given us some some indication
so I'd support that thank you'd your
hand up I did um thank you
um I am in the grants
um I think it's really important that
the public get to have a democracy and
an involvement in what we choose to be
and how really did in the next trainium
I think to not go out to consultation
with them would be a very bad mistake
okay Allah
um well I prefer first pass the post
it's just my preference purely because
it's simple but in saying that I'm quite
happy to go out to public consultation
but or sorry sorry for their views but
we need to ensure that it's very broadly
advertised so we get a very good
cross-section of the community's
representations of views back to us not
just uh shouldn't just be on our website
it should be should be very widely thing
because it's quite a quite a big issue
it's a huge issue well as both needs to
be weirdly advertised but also well
explained doesn't it because yeah yeah
so although anybody else want to come in
thank you ringing
just on the um potential 16 year old uh
vote thing you know since it's on the in
the item I mean
back in 1974 we went from 21 to 18.
um 50 years later we're at this point
now looking at 16 year olds I mean soon
I mean you moved to 16 then the next
step where do you go from there 14 year
old are we going to crashes to get it
you know every that we're having blocks
you know to vote with
um I note that uh 18 years old to fight
for your country now that's critical age
and it's a critical statement as well
of of maturity you have to be 18 years
old
um I just I just hope that people in
Wellington actually have a bit more
common sense and actually realize
um rather than maybe they think only 16
year olds were the only people are going
to vote for them you know I don't know
because they put vaping forward or
something into the immediate question
would you
do you think that we should put the
certainty public consultation not that
question but the question of
um whether we should have an STV or a
first-person post system
because that's the only question that
we've been asked to decide no no I I
actually think we should
we don't do that if we're going to do
that we should go out and have a uh have
a pulp because what's going to come back
is feedback and then we'll interpret the
feedback wherever we want to we're back
to square one again and you would have
wasted all that time Consulting
um we've already had the vote here and
as Darren said it was the girls versus
boys
um so if we if we're serious about about
this going out to consultation let's put
it out to a poll otherwise I think at
the moment
um I think five who argue that it should
go to consultation right but I mean any
anybody else want to comment
no okay looking for emotion then so um
Darren would you want to put forward
emotion so I move that we receive the
report elected electoral matters update
confirm that we do wish to consult with
the community on the issue of what
election system to use
are you sickening Leslie
um is there any more discussion
and if not
um those in favor say aye High against
you
but so the motion is that it goes to
consultation yeah so three is being
deleted is it
yeah or right yeah
yeah do you wish to go against no well
yeah I'm definitely voting against I see
it as a waste of time we'll just be back
here talking the same talk we did yes
okay A bit of the less emotions carried
thank you when it gets to the the
question of a representation review and
given that that would be triggered
unless we decided it and I think we you
know we the the next phase of this is
obviously going to be bringing back the
result of that consultation and how
quickly will that be Michael so the
decision must be made by September so I
expect that we would uh and we'll work
with Rihanna and her team to ensure that
there is consultation going out as soon
as we can how quickly will we uh what's
difficult to see but this question of
um the government's view on uh whether
they would require us to have a merry
seat or whether they would require us to
consult on it how quickly would that be
we will know in April um
and that will trigger a representation
review and part of that representation
review would obviously be whether we do
FTV or first place to post no no it'll
be too late yeah they'll be too late so
the if um the single transfer will
provide if first pass the PO decision
must be made by September well but I
thought you said yeah I thought you said
that we would know oh do you mean April
next year before you know it's bad days
so that's one part the second part is
the Maori Ward question when that piece
of legislation is in the house at the
moment expected to be passed in April
April this year April this year so that
was the point I was making so but you'll
know that soon enough won't be that we
could decide to make a to have a
representation review at that point in
fact we would be required to I think
from what you see so only if we were to
determine to determine to have a mighty
Ward but that would be the way to do
that wouldn't that would be the process
by which you would decide that and and
it would be and part of that wouldn't
party that then be the part of that
representation review all being done
running about the middle of this year
wouldn't that include whether we
listening to the consultation results
whether we go to STV um stay as we are
yeah so unfortunately the consultation
required for a representation review
would take significantly longer than
would be available uh to us to complete
the suvsp fpp uh decision and the
representation review would only be
required if we uh were to choose a
mighty Ward because we did a
representation review last term
okay as if you can choose at any time to
do a representation review
um okay so my question really was about
what are the things would be done
sequentially whether they should be
trade we should trade wrap up together
it seems as though they must be done
sequentially so so following the the
consultation process on STV
um you'll bring that back in did you see
a couple of months or something right so
we went to have it back well in advance
of September uh once I have worked with
Rhiannon and her team we'll be back with
a plan on how we're going to do this so
that you can be informed so that you can
be involved okay and in April I see you
real and then April we'll
um will better knowledge about
um the government's position on Mary
Ward and that can be debated yes
um I wonder whether it's more suitable
to a workshop than it is to you know to
being done in Council but you might
think about that you know there's a lot
of issues here which the difficulty deal
with and the formality of a council and
it may be better for more open
discussion and debate it may be you know
better to do in a workshop type
situation look absolutely Mr chair at
all depending on what the ACT ultimately
says when it has passed through the
house uh there may be a reason and a
Justified reason to have a good Workshop
to discuss all of those issues or it
could be something as simple as the ACT
is very straightforward and there's very
little choice on what we do so let's
just report back to that
Council but absolutely I take your point
and we'll work on that okay real so um
3M Stitch here Michael I just I'm
seeking some a clarification or process
um to do with um an item on on the table
what I'm sticking to clarification over
is we're going to seek public
consultation
so when that comes back into Council
after it's been filtered through
that is neither binding on the council
great so then that comes to rangi's
concern about this process being a waste
of time and effort well no because
before I'm just trying to seek
application of that process but it
doesn't form this debate though yeah I
mean if Constitution comes back with 90
of people in favor of STV then I mean I
think we were just going against us yeah
okay any other questions or
so is there anything else that needs to
be moved at this point or have we if
that is unplate thank you Mr chair okay
then thank you very much thank you
so that takes us to tab 16 amendments to
the delegation register
all you're going to do with this is
filmmaker yes this is me I've taken over
from Rhiannon
um and I presume I presume you can go
straight to appendix 2 and yes we can do
it through that I don't think there's
any need for huge explanation I think Mr
chair it's very very obvious um as
syndicated um by the mere last time
we're here he wished to um have that
change made to uh
the definitions around elected members
we've now edited in that monofino
Representatives I do apologize to both
of them I have missed macron and runaka
and I will have that corrected before it
uh is published so I do apologize for
that
we have made a few changes to financial
delegations
and just updating operational changes
there and we've also had taken the
opportunity
um
to make changes to some staff
delegations under the resource
management act so uh there is really
nothing much else I need to say here so
we can um progress on and
I'm happy to answer any questions any
questions yes just a point of clarity
if you wanted our legal name legal names
Evelyn noted um
it's probably me being a little bit
um pedantic but we're actually appointed
by uh
and offered to you anyway for acceptance
we come from our ewe it's not
for the council to say we don't want
Evelyn we'd rather have so and so so I
wonder about the wording of that who are
appointed by Council to represent so um
you are unfortunately appointed by
Council following nomination by odunaka
um
that's that's how the Local Government
Act requires this I do take your point
that you are offered by
um both I hope I and our uh to us
however the the ACT requires when we
make non-elected appointments to our
committees that Council appoints them
yes but the point I'm making is that it
doesn't reflect that it's our renaka
that actually make those um nominations
the council kind of point it but
um if you turn down who the the runaka
appointed that would be a different
issue so it sounds like
and the way that it's rooted here it
sounds like that the council gets to
decide who the runica chooses is there
another way we can word that that still
meets them well so well can I can I
propose where you simply say who are
nominated by renaka and appointed by
Council I mean I don't think that would
be a problem with me yeah no absolutely
I was about to suggest something uh the
same and then I was going to ask would
you prefer me to spell out the legal
names for both
rather than just refer to you generic to
them the organization's generally
if you're happy to make that change good
thank you
thanks Michael nothing knows
so
do you need a mover for the three a big
part and we haven't done that yet have
we
okay oh you move
thank you is it a second is there any
more discussion
those in favor say aye aye against
carried thank you
all right bro
so that leads us to tab 17 the minutes
of the risk and Assurance committee
meeting held on the 21st of March
um well someone moves that we received
those
Thank You leslan seconded by Dan those
in favor say aye
aye against carried
um that concludes the public yeah sorry
I just wanted to comment on the on the
minutes is it a bigger pardon usually
okay
um look it's it's the comment is
regarding trying to understand go to
page 180 of board books and I'm going
down to
um item five a it says note the role of
the risk and Assurance committee and
monitoring risks including against risk
appetite I'm just trying to understand
is that is that supposed to be written
like that or
so mustian page one Yeti but I can't
find the sentence just talking about
180.
down the bottom 5A
oh
I see I'm just trying to work out
probably deal with deleting against it
still makes sense yeah yeah I'm just
just telling you if we're going to
receive this and it's it should be
monitoring risks comma
including risk appetite so take out
against okay
it is actually in there because it's
important that the risks are monitored
in the context yeah
itself if we have discussed
against the documents that's already
predetermined service
sorry to just interrupt um it's because
there was a change put proposed by uh
Mia Clarke that you will see on page 181
which would make that change and delete
against
um so if you follow if you go through to
page 181 it is then shown because there
was a change to the motion as proposed
by Mia Clarke
he's yeah which then makes that 5A is
monitoring risks monitoring risks
apologies for that confusion there it
was just how procedurally that happened
on the day
I remember
so at least we forget
I think we had so I think we actually
already approved that so we can move on
I think
um I think that concludes the public
part of the meeting will somebody move
that we move into public excluded thank
you Alan and
so you can bye buddy who's in favor say
aye aye against carried